bré les photos c'est avec cette simple
déclaration accroché en silence aux
grilles du palais de buckingham que la
mort du prince philippe a été annoncée
un peu après 12h30
c'est avec un profond chagrin que sa
majesté la reine a annoncé la mort de
son mari vient et met son altesse royale
le prince philip duc d'edimbourg
twitter est un match au même moment
cette présentatrice de la bbc
visiblement ému transmettait si les
mêmes mots au sujet britannique et au
reste du monde
le premier ministre a été le premier à
saluer la vie du prince consort louis
gates fait la nation et le royaume offre
leurs remerciements pour la vie le
travail extraordinaire du prince philip
duc d'edimbourg a déclaré boris johnson
devant downing street au palais de
buckingham des fleurs et des messages de
sympathie parfois tout simple mais pas
d'attroupement qu'ovide oblige je crois
qu'on se souviendra de son esprit
effrontée je crois qu'il est connu pour
les choses qu'il a pu dire mais surtout
pour ce qu'il a fait pour la reine des
claires venues lui rendre hommage
le prince philippe avec une personnalité
pour le moins complexe il était connu
pour son caractère rugueux son
tempérament fougueux son langage peu
protocolaire on le disait direct cassant
autoritaire et colérique il a souvent
mis buckingham dans l'embarras avec des
propos tantôt sexistes quant aux
racistes ou complètement dépourvu de
sensibilité mais il avait du charisme de
l'humour
c'est lui je n'ai souffler un vent de
modernité à la monarchie pour ne pas
qu'elle disparaisse
le prince philippe est né sur l'île de
corfou en grèce prince de grèce et du
danemark
son enfance difficile se déroule en exil
adolescent il rejoint les rangs de la
marine royale c'est là à dartmouth qu'il
rencontre elisabeth
pour elle il renonce à ses titres et à
sa religion orthodoxe le prince de nulle
part comme il était surnommé à
buckingham devient le lieutenant philip
mountbatten il épouse elisabeth en
grande pompe en 1947
les jeunes mariés vont s'établir à malte
alors que le prince philippe poursuit sa
carrière d'officier de la marine royale
et sa carrière militaire prend fin avec
la mort du roi georges 6 et le
couronnement de son épouse en 1952
de leur union forget d'un amour mutuel
indéfectible naissent quatre enfants
charles and andrew et edward c'est à lui
que revient principalement le rôle de
les éduquer
alors que des centaines de milliers de
familles au royaume uni ont été privés
de cérémonie funéraire pour les leurres
remporté par l'aco vide
il règne encore ce soir un certain flou
autour des détails du deuil de la
famille royale
les cérémonies ne seront pas des
funérailles d'état ils ne seront pas
précédée d'une chapelle ardente
la dépouille du prince philippe restera
au château de windsor dans la tente des
funérailles à la chapelle saint georges
en soirée les cloches de westminster ont
retenti 99 fois une fois pour chaque
année qu a duré la vie du prince philip
une vie marquée plus que tout par son
dévouement à une femme celle qui la rend
compris pour la première fois alors
qu'il avait 18 ans celle dont il est
tombé amoureux ici marie ève bédard à
radio canada paris